the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire update video all
right my friends in this video i will be
delivering some very good news as well
as some bad news unfortunately the first
thing i want to do is discuss the great
news which has to do with the new jon
snow sequel series that's in development
at hbo as i'm sure most of you know by
now hbo as well as kid harrington are
developing a jon snow show set in
westeros based on what is happening with
this character after the events of the
original series game of thrones
as you all know at the end of game of
thrones we saw jon snow ghost and the
small faction of wildlings heading north
of the wall for a destination unknown
now according to george rr martin mr
harrington wants to make a series about
the adventures of jon snow as of right
now no one really knows what the show
will be about the one thing we do know
is mr harrington brought the idea to hbo
himself not only was he the one who
wants to make the show but he also
brought on his own writers and directors
to help him make this idea of his into a
reality now before the information was
even announced i'd been saying for
months that i believe a lot of the
actors and actresses from game of
thrones would eventually wish they were
in westeros once again
although some of them did want a break
from game of thrones after working on
the show for nearly a decade i knew that
one day they would be ready to come back
now i don't mean for this to sound
negative but game of thrones will most
likely be the biggest thing some of them
will ever work on i mean it still is the
most successful show in the history of
television so it's no wonder that would
be the case unfortunately for some of
these actors they might never be in
something that's recognizable again it's
one of the reasons why it was so hard
for kid harrington to have to walk away
from jon snow it had become such a big
part of his identity which is very
understandable
a lot of athletes go through this same
exact thing whenever they have to step
away from their game
well we're now starting to find out that
a lot of the actors from game of thrones
are more than ready to come back to
westeros
since many of them were still alive at
the end of the show that door is still
open for them to make an appearance in
some form or fashion in this new jon
snow series
maisie williams who was arya stark has
already more or less said she would be
interested in showing back up in
westeros again
well now she's not the only one on
record who has said this in a recent
article we found out there is several
more actors who want to step back into
their roles again gwendolyn christie
whose fan favorite character brienne
survived the bloody series said the
newsweek brianne is incredibly close to
my heart and i would relish any
opportunity to revisit her
then another one of the actors basically
said the same thing
john bradley who was john's best friend
samwell left the door open as well
he said i haven't spoken to anybody
about the jon snow sequel but if
somebody wants to send a script my way
i'd be interested to read it now believe
me when i say this i know for a fact
they're not the only ones who are
feeling that way we just haven't had a
chance to hear what the other actors
think about the new show as of right now
we might see jon snow arya stark brienne
and samwell again
they're all still alive and interested
in what might be happening in westeros
after the events of the original series
i don't know about all of you but game
of thrones season 9 is starting to look
more and more like it could actually
become a reality we're now only a few
ingredients away from actually making
this happen
now i believe hbo is watching and their
eyes are on the fans feedback so if you
really want this show to happen you
gotta sound off in the comments section
and let hbo know that you want to see
more game of thrones i'm sure they want
to know if there's any real interest in
the jon snow show don't hesitate to say
that you're ready for more because i
know i am as always i will let you know
if any new information is announced
regarding this show
now let's get on to the bad news
unfortunately george rr martin had a
message for his fans that wasn't as
exciting now the good thing is he does
seem to be fine and as long as it stays
that way it shouldn't have any effect on
the successor shows or even his writing
on the winds of winter have a listen for
yourself
hi guys this is uh george r martin
coming to you uh via video uh rather
than my usual um posts on not a blog
because
i'm away from my computer and i'm here
in a hotel room
in los angeles
um
as you may know from my
post on not a blog before i departed on
this trip i had a trip to the west coast
starting at san diego comic-con
for the um big panel on house of dragon
the new successor show to game of
thrones
and
that was to be followed by a week in los
angeles where i had a lot of meetings
and i had two big premiers
and then a few other things um
but
uh you know the best laid plans of mice
and men
as robert burns once said
[Music]
san diego
went well
although with kovid raging
in san diego county in california in
general
i decided to be very cautious and
conservative i i did the panel
and that was a lot of fun and uh it's
it's online many of you can see it there
but i skipped all of the parties i did
not go on the convention floor
and
i cancelled my
in-person autographing so i did sign
hundreds of books and comic books and
posters to sell or give away so my
signature was available at comic-con
and i went out for a few meals
and that was fine and then we drove up
to los angeles
for the second leg of this trip well
a funny thing happened
and
the
first day
in los angeles yesterday i woke up
and tested positive for covid
um
you may have heard that by now i guess
rumors had a way of spreading out on the
internet
and yes i am positive for kovid uh it
came up i was as startled as any of you
because i did not really think i had any
uh symptoms
uh or very very minor systems i was
sniffling a little
and that's pretty much still where i am
this is the second day i'm still
sniffling a little
and uh occasionally coughing but mostly
i feel fine but
i was hoping it was a false positive we
took the test a second time we took the
test a third time a different kind of
test
and
all of them give the same result that i
am indeed
positive
and what that means of course is i can't
do uh most of the things that i was
planning to do
here in los angeles i'm um
quarantined
and
even more sadly um
my wife paris
some of my fantastic minions like sid
and rhea and dahlia
and elias who who came with me to uh
assist me and be part of these premieres
since they had
been exposed to me they also had to uh
quarantine
um because otherwise they could be
spreaders even though all of them are
negative
so
that's where we are now
um but i didn't want to leave the matter
unaddressed i wanted to say a few words
about it
um
honestly
it's a mystery to me how in the world i
i got this because um i am positive but
everybody around me is negative um and
all of the people i
i ate with in san diego
um
all of the people who uh who assisted me
from here and there all of them are
negative
i'm the only positive person in uh in
this particular group um
but it is what it is i guess said and
and i'm fully you know i don't take any
chances with that i've been very careful
i'm uh
fully vaccinated and i've had two
booster shots
and i got the uh
the best mask that one could possibly
get
and uh wore it in all
public settings uh
the only exceptions being when i was
actually sitting on that panel in whole
age and when i was eating uh because
they haven't figured out how to do a
mask get that'll enable you to eat
through it
but this virus is tricky so here i am um
i feel a little sniffly
um but really
nothing
bad uh i've had worse colds so i hope it
will stay that way for the duration of
its run
and uh that after this quarantine period
i will uh you know be able to
resume and uh do a few things at the
tail end and then head on back to santa
fe
to get catch up on all the emails and
resume more than the wins of winter and
mine numerous other projects
so
you